I think that's so bizarre to me is that
we're sitting here and we're talking
about the age like the wise,
if guns were just created like
you know when in reality, right,
but something's wrong. But what's
wrong is it the, it's not the guns.
I'm asking you, what do you think
is wrong? Mental Health, right?
So I say I agree with you,
but I think it should the two
ration of culture altogether.
Like they used to be taught the Bible
in school. Like you know what people,
people make fun of that now.
Like now we've got this culture
where you're making fun of kids.
Like religion is like,
we're so far away from religion.
Like that's like weird to us. Like you
know like teaching religion is like, it's,
you've got like an oak scarlet letter.
If you come in as like a crow,
a holy Christian kid in like a
normal public public education thing,
you've got the family structure where
it's like these kids are running the
houses these days.
Like I look on like Facebook and it's
like supposed to be funny when like a four
year old is acting like Cardi B.
I'm like okay.
Yes it's funny cause she's four but it's
also like not funny cause she's four,
right? Like how do you feel about Little
Tang? Who's a little tay? I Love Cardi B.
I know a little tay is,
it was time.
He's kind of out of the news now
because they found that it's a hustle.
She's a nine year old
Asian girl from what?
Vancouver and she talks mad shit,
throws money around,
calls everybody bitches and haters yet.
But that's my point.
Like this is considered like funny. It's
like entertaining, like the fact that,
and we're okay with that.
And so parents are pushing their kids to
be more outrageous cause there's a way
that they can make it. So to me it's
like hanging out with Rick Ruben.
She looks like she's, she like, how
old is she? She looks like she's,
Oh those are hooks at the horns up and
she's got a g wagon in front of this.
It's just like the cash me outside girl.
Right.
So we don't talk about any of that.
We don't talk about the fact that
that we no longer focus on family.
We know it's no longer just focused
on religion. Doesn't need to be,
does it mean to be that
everyone needs to be religious,
but their structure and religion
right there structure in, in me,
when I grew up in and my grandpa used to
make us read the Bible around the table,
there was some structure to that
and lessons and prayers that,
and then there's this mass, the, the
Facebook, the snap, the snapping, the,
the Instagram or Twitter.
It's like we've changed the world and
expected children to say in stay the same
of it and nobody talks about it. So he
said, they say it's the gun's fault.
We need to,
we need stricter gun gun legislation,
but the entire world has shifted.
We're not talking about those changes.
The dynamic of the world that has shifted.
So I, I just hold a different position.
I, you know, I think it starts with
family. It starts with structure.
I think we need,
we need religion back.
I think that that needs to stop being
such a dirty word and to stop being mocked
roundly by the media. Like it shouldn't
be funny. You know, when joy bay, um,
you know, says something about Jesus
and the whole audience giggles.
That's weird.
Mike pence because he talks to Jesus
did give a how weird that is, right?
Like how weird that the stuff that we
used to would be normal. Like you know,
praying,
talking with you.
You just like when I grew up that
was like my grandparents' generation.
That was everyone was religious and now
we're so far away from that, right. That,
that,
that seems like,
like it's okay to mock and we roundly
mocked it all the time. So these are the,
the structure in the home is,
in my opinion,
the most important thing
that needs to change.
The fact that some people are growing
up without fathers in the home is
something that needs to change.
Letting your kid have a Facebook account
when they're seven, right? Like it just,
there's just too much.
It's the information age,
but what information are they downloading?
Well,
I definitely think that
people need structure.
I definitely think that people need
family and community and all those good
things, but when it comes to religion,
it's like, which one is right as a hobby,
right? It's not about being right.
Yeah. It doesn't sound like there's not,
I know I'm going to be honest. I know
nothing about Scientology, so I'm not,
I know that people hate Scientology.
That's all that all I know
about it created by a science
fiction writer and it's
all nonsense. Right? That's all
you need to know. Okay. Yeah.
So it's one of the dumbest religions of
all time. If you read like what they are,
Leah Remini who was in it for years,
I didn't watch her series.
She been on my podcast and she explained
her journey into it and what happened
with it and when she started to question
it. And there's a whole thing there.
There's a, um, what is the fucking
Hbo Documentary? It's also the book,
the HBO on Scientology.
The Lawrence Wright going
clear. Going clear. Yeah.
I read the book and I watched
the documentary. So crazy boy,
I know nothing about it besides like
Tom Cruise, I'm going to be like,
I'm going to be honest with totally
ignorant. It's, you know, for some people,
here's the thing, for some people
its structure and its helpful, right?
Ideologies are helpful sometimes
because they give you like a,
like a format to live your life by
or scaffolding to keep your, your,
your moral beliefs inside
of these boundaries.
And it helps you get ahead and you
have purpose in decision making.
But at the end of the day it's a cult,
you know, and there's a lot of them.
So a lot of different ones.
So like how do you decide that
there's something that comes from,
I think just learning certain lessons.
It doesn't need to be too,
I'm not saying that we owe
something like structure structure.
Like the Bible used to be
taught in school objectively,
they would be taught by people that, you
know, we're not practicing Christians.
Right.
Um,
used to be taught in school objectively
because there's still lessons that are
timeless in these Bible stories. It's
something to do with whether or not your,
you don't need to then say,
oh,
and then we go to church and then we
pray in school and all that stuff.
You can almost extract that and try to
teach these lessons objectively. But,
but kids are learning now is like how
to be an anarchist. Like you know,
feminism one o one and every,
it's,
you're like actually fostering an angry
culture by telling them at every turn if
they should be outraged. We are
in outrage culture. And then your,
your surprise when somebody does
something outrageous. Right?
It's a little bizarre to me. It's like,
oh, everything should piss you off.
Everything should make you angry.
Everything should make you upset.
Everything is up. Just as
unjust. Everything is oppressed.
And I don't know why this kid just show
up at school. I see. So angry or weird.
It's like we're weirdly fake. I
know whatsapp, the conversation,
the shooting happens and
everyone's talking about the NRA.
And then David Hogg is back on the news.
Jordan Peterson has some interesting
ideas about religion and the fundamental
beliefs and um,
the lessons
that are learned from things like the
Bible and how they apply to human life and
that our,
our own belief systems without them,
without the sort of structures and
belief systems is one of the things that
leads civilization astray and that it's
done that before and things go awry.
Well I actually had this debate
with Charlie and I did a panel,
I'm down in DC and we were talking
about whether like, you know,
the reintroduction of,
of God and teaching them to school.
And I said like at some point
there seems to be the struggle.
I have this idea that like
human beings in a certain way,
we're doomed to just keep
repeating history. I'm
obsessed with Greek mythology.
I'll obsessed with like Egyptian history
hieroglyphic like anything that like w
where they tell stories,
especially Greek mythology because the
lessons are there and we just keep doing
it. Right? Greed, lust, like the things
that human beings fall for. Right.
So I had this idea when we were talking,
cause Charlie is,
is an evangelical Christian.
I'm not right. I believe in, I,
I the super smart guys and
Evangelical Christians.
Does he believe like Jesus came back to
life? Yes. Really? Yes. He's an Mhl group
believes that someone died.
Yeah. And then three years,
three days later they came back to
life and that they walked on water and
yeah,
I mean you have to,
I haven't really gotten into
with him because I'm not like,
I'm not the person that should ever be
like debating or talking about religion.
It's not my shtick I guess. Um,
but so what, what I said to him,
cause me and him both
believe that in many ways,
the reason that the government has,
uh,
the media has started roundly
dissing Dodd, right? Like in dissing,
he says Christ is because the
government wants to be God. Right.
So if people don't know,
do you think the media is responding
to the government suggestion?
Is that what you think
the reason why people
religion is because the media is
responding to some sort of orders from the
government orders. That's, that's wrong.
So it's, it's, it's directive. No, no,
but you know,
Andrew,
Andrew Breitbart said that politics
is downstream from culture, right? So,
and you can argue that they feed into
each other, whatever it is, but there's,
there's definitely something, um, between
culture and politics that is linked,
inextricably linked. Um,
so, uh, when, you know,
when everyone's on the same page, like,
so if the government wants to get bigger,
which it has been doing right, and wants
people to look to them for answers,
which it has been doing,
you have to understand,
they have to sort of destroy everything
else that they would potentially be
looking to for answers.
Right?
So instead of when you're down and out
and people would just go to church and
pray, right? Or believing in your
family or the family structure,
they need to know that no matter what
you think the government is the answer.
That is what a leftist,
at the end of the day,
the glut believes the government can
fix all of their problems. And, uh,
and I find, especially when
I speak lot, I love us.
They do not believe in religion. Like,
and there's just a thing. It's a trend.
I've noticed that, you know, I'm not
religious, I'm not saying that, you know,
there's something wrong with it,
but leftists tend to be, you know,
really apart from religion.
So you could make,
the argument could definitely be made that
the destruction of believing in Bible,
of stop teaching the Bible is because you
want to make it so that every time you
have a problem that cause
you're still going to our soul.
We still need to believe in something.
We're naturally beings that we need to
believe that something can fix something.
I really believe that that is the reason
why we go get our palms red, right?
Like we just like there's,
there's something else.
Somebody has the answer and people are
starting to believe it's government in
America and it freaks me out.
I agree with you that
people like structure,
and I agree with you that people without
religion try to find that structure and
those rules and other things.
But I don't believe that this is like
some calculated government by nature.
I think it's human nature shifts.